ouais c'est ça c'est lui le deuxième que
vous étiez en ce moment bienvenue chez
otaku une librairie de la rue
saint-denis spécialisé en mangas ces
bandes dessinées japonaises
en affaires depuis 2010 pense
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut être
concurrentiels dans le commerce de
détail
il faut pas qu'on soit là juste pour
faire faire une transaction au
consommateur ou à la personne
il faut que qu'on lui apporte une
expérience on a quelque chose de plus le
nom otaku a été choisi justement pour
évoquer cette expérience
l'expression japonaise veut dire comme à
la maison
j'ai certes à examiner fois pour manger
les feuilles truc qui est lancée et
identité aussi salon de lecture jeux de
société même des cours de japonais sont
offerts ici tout ça entre autres pour
rivaliser avec les géants du web dont
amazon
ils ont accès à des prix qui sont plus
plus intéressant que les nôtres ils
peuvent grâce à la taille du commerce
faire car la livraison gratuite
est-ce que ça va arriver un jour que nos
gouvernements 7 cm de boue à quinze
c'est la porte d'entrée
cette libraire d'expérience a elle aussi
dû diversifier son offre
chez pauline il y à des conférences des
causeries des activités familiales
mais selon la directrice il faut
s'attaquer au coeur du problème
pourquoi par exemple que le libre à
nouveau payer ses terres depuis son choc
avec un on paie des taxes tout ça peut
mettre 3 qu'amazon mené et on est
dispensé certains cantons sont en manque
mais le portrait n'est peut-être pas si
sombre qui a eu des années 2012 2013
2014 où il y avait eu près de
dizaine de fermetures par année cet
autre chose dans les palaces la
coopérative des librairies indépendantes
du québec constate plutôt que les choses
vont bien ces jours ci les chiffres sont
là l'appui les vins sont pas en
progressant de 5% au cours des trois
dernières années
est-ce que des clients des fois qu'ils
vous disent pas laisser tomber
finalement je vais commander sur amazon
tous les jours ah oui oui bien sûr il ya
ces gens là aussi qu'ils vont dire ben
oui je sais que je peux l'avoir sur
amazon plus rapidement mais j'ai envie
de vous encourager
grâce à eux les librairies indépendantes
résiste ici sébastien desrosiers
radio-canada mourir